Les mesures annoncées ce soir
pour faire face au variant
Omicron sont-elles adaptées à
la situation, est-ce qu'elles
arrivent trop tard? Je poursuis
avec le Dre Cécile Tremblay,
microbiologiste infectiologue,
au CHUM. Comment réagissez-vous
aux mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement ce soir?
- Elles étaient nécessaires et
j'étais contente qu'on les
annonce. je pense qu'il faut
agir sur les deux fronts,
accélérer la vaccination de la
troisième dose et limiter les
comptes si on veut préserver
notre système de santé durant le
temps des Fêtes.
- qu'est-ce qui renda
situation si critique?
Plus les cas se multiplient plus
il y a d'hospitalisation?
- C'est un effet domino. si sûr
qu'on n'est pas encore certain
de la Sibérie et du variant
Omicron mais fort probablement
qu'il est similaire au delta
donc imaginait si on a 10 fois
plus de cas en termes de
pourcentage des gens
hospitalisés c'est sûr que ça va
occasionner plus
d'hospitalisation. s'il y a
beaucoup de transmissions
communautaires ou sa doublure de
jour comme en ce moment le
personnel de la santé devient
malade et quand ils sont
atteints de la cabine et doivent
être en quarantaine donc ça
donne des ressources encore
moins dans les hôpitaux pour
prendre soins des patients par
que la capacité du système c'est
pas juste les lits, c'est aussi
le personnel pour s'en occuper.
on pourrait à mon avis atteindre
une capacité maximale avant même
le mois de janvier.
- c'est intéressant parc
pense toujours que le virus qui
est plus contagieux mais moins
virulent et moins dangereux?
- On est même pas certain qu'il
est moins virulent, les données
du Danemark qui
variants depuis plusieurs
semaines et qui ont eu le temps
de faire des ss,s,s,s,s,s, leur
taux d'hospitalisation avec les
variant Omicron est le même
qu'avec le Dell. . 81% dans
l'alcool ce n'est pas lui qui
l'était moins virulent. en
Afriqu'é'é'é'é'é'était plus
différent mais la population est
plus différente ils sont plus
jeunes et exposés déjà desesesee
de se faire une idée sur la
virulence de ces microbes.- maie
les deux doses ne sont pas
suffisantes ça prend cette
troisième dose. est-ce que le
gouvernement n'a pas tardé à
élargir l'accès aux vaccins?
- Ça fait plusieurs semaines que
plusieurs d'entre nous suivons
l'importance et la nécessité
d'administrer la troisième dose
le plus rapidement possible.
savait déjà été déterminé par
plusieurs juridictions que ce
soit celle de la santé publi
en Europe ou les Américains et
même le Canada don
monde s'entend déposer et que ça
prenait une troisième dose, même
dans le contexte du delta parce
qu'on sentait qu
commence à baisser dans la
population générale surtout chez
les personnes âgées mais aussi
dans la population générale.
alors avec l'Omicron qui on sait
qui est plus
vaccins, ça va de soi. et
Omicron ont t t t t t t t depuin
mois déjà c'est pas juste deux
semaines, il n'est pas apparu la
semaine dernière, ça fait un
mois qu'on est au courant de ce
variants est clairement la bonne
onononononononononséquent avec
la troisième dose ça réussit à
créer aussi notre communauté
suffisamment pour nous protéger
correctement contre Omicron. on
sait qu'on a un outil efficace
et c'est d'autant plus importans
rapidement possible.
- vous êtes d'accord avec lefafe
délai entre la deuxième et la
troisième dose?
- Tout à fait parce que ce
délai-là était arbitraire il
était établi à partir de données
qui démontraient que l'immunité
commence à baisser à six mois
après avoir reçu la deuxième
dose, dans la population
générale. n'en savait que ça
baissait pas mal avança dans les
autres groupes. l'intervalle de
six mois c'était pou
c'était pas vraiment nécessaire
de l'administrer avant, mes
Omicron sont ça donne
complètement parce qu'on sait
que l'immunité innée plus bonne
du tout pour l
population après deux autres
importe le délai. en Europe ces
trois mois, et si on a décidé
quatre mois. moi je pense qu'on
douvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvre pour
accélérer la vaccination de
toute la population. je suis
papapapapapapapapapapar tranche
d'âge en mettant les plus
vulnérables en premier mais ça
doit se faire très vite.
- malheureusement n'a pas encore
tous les bras pour donner ce
vaccin. en terminant la
réduction des contacts est
nécessaire parce que lainininine
finalement?
- Si on vaccine les gens
maintenant leur immunité sera
seulement rehaussée dans deux
semaines. Qu'est-ce qu'on en
mesure comme en ce moment c'est
diminué les contacts. je sais
que c'est difficile, pour moi
aussi c'est difficile. on
voulu voir notre famille de
façon plus élargie durant le
temps des Fêtes et puis tout
cela, mais on sait que dans le
fond on fait ça pour protéger
les gens qu'on aime. c
difficile, c'est un effort
supplémentaire mais c'est ce
qu'il y a de plus efficace pour
empêcher la propagation. se
laver les mains, p
masque, des petits
rassemblements, protéger les
personnes vu
tous quelqu'un dans notre
famille qui a eu le cancer et ça
serait vraiment poste